i got the cte from fight
post concussion
so i can't inspire anymore i wouldn't
would have liked it maybe but i can't
get hit no more
and i'm actually donating my brain when
i pass because i'm in that study mike
with the with the football players and
all that i'm good with it because i stay
healthy and stuff you know i mean so and
all that but uh there's a lot of guys
out there that don't remember their own
name or walk right before the scene you
know what i mean and it's sad you know
what i mean but uh so i said
i tell you what make it for you for
being a lot of uh for being in a lot of
wars when i just saw that and you know
all the fights
man i wouldn't you know people didn't
know you'd be like i don't know if he's
you know yeah and i'm good i'm good my
wife can see it because i get like angry
there's differences there's different
things with concussions
because people can go to drink and drugs
people do this people want to hurt
people people want to be here whatever
it might be like there's all different
effects from concussions
people get tired people get angry people
get whatever it is